this episode was made possible by
cheddar in their new YouTube channel
that covers business technology media
and news but without the boring parts be
sure to check out their video on
preventing a robot uprising after this
[Music]
let's get one fact straight it's only a
matter of time before we successfully
create an AI that surpasses the
intelligence of a human being
estimates for this event known as the
singularity range from anywhere between
10 and 50 years from now what happens
next is anyone's guess
but there are two prevailing theories
one humanity is fast tracked for more
amazing technological innovation than
we've experienced in our entire history
or to extinction at the hands of a
sentient super AI who is indifferent to
our survival let's back up a little bit
there are a few distinctions to make
when talking about advanced AI on the
low end of the intelligence spectrum
there's weak or narrow AI software that
is useful within a fairly limited range
of tasks Alexa Siri and all the other
personal assistants are the most obvious
examples but we're actually surrounded
by narrow AI your Netflix caters to your
taste in movies and TV Amazon predicts
the kind of products you like based on
your browsing habits and your purchase
history machine learning algorithms
represent another form of narrow AI any
program that can adapt based upon user
interaction can be lumped into this
category this type of artificial
intelligence is rarely considered a
threat take Siri for example there's no
real intelligence there no mind no
self-awareness she'll answer some
questions for you but she's completely
useless outside the scope of even fairly
simple ones moving up one level we have
artificial general intelligence or AGI
this type of AI is able to apply its
intelligence to a much wider range of
applications and can successfully
perform any intellectual action a human
can this level of AI is generally the
goal for projects aiming to develop an
advanced artificial intelligence
academics often refer to AGI with the
ability to experience consciousness as
strong AI think Hal from 2001 a Space
Odyssey or the t800 from terminator or
Ava from ex machina these are machines
or software that are just as intelligent
or more intelligent than humans but have
not entered a state of runaway
self-improvement that would lead to the
next stage of AI as of 2017 there were
at least 40 organizations around the
world actively researching AGI now for
the big one
artificial superintelligence
this is the level of AI that some of the
world's leading experts believe could
spell the end of mankind a super
intelligence would be smarter and more
capable than all of humanity's greatest
minds put together and getting more
intelligent every second these AI would
seem like God's to us mere mortals
infinite knowledge the ability to
perform countless tasks at once instant
answers to questions we haven't even
thought of yet
the biggest question we have thought of
regarding a super AI is whether or not
it'll be friendly when we think of
modern AI we think of giving it a task
and at performing that task then waiting
for the next command it's not friendly
or unfriendly it just performs its task
what happens when we have a vastly more
capable AI and we task it with ending
world hunger the easiest solution for
the AI would be to eliminate humans and
thus end world hunger for good that may
sound like a far-fetched example but
consider how the AI would see humans we
look at insects and have little regard
for their lives because they're
insignificant and more importantly far
less intelligent than we are we step on
ants without a moment's hesitation how
would an entity millions of times more
intelligent than humans be likely to
treat us we tend to disregard the danger
because we assume AI will be human-like
after all we're making it in our own
image this arrogance could lead us to
develop a sentient machine that would
see our existence as nothing more than a
nuisance a parasite that causes more
damage than anything else on the planet
in that regard the machine would be
right and if it considered us a threat
to its own existence it's unlikely that
we could do anything to stop our
ultimate destruction how can we stop a
being that has access to all of our
knowledge and more can control our
computer systems can create and destroy
at will by using our already existing
infrastructure or worse by building its
own that is far beyond human
understanding
if this super AI is truly sentient it
would be able to communicate with us but
whether we would even merit that
communication is up in the air this is
why some of the leading experts expect
true artificial intelligence to be our
final invention the greatest achievement
in history that leads to our own
destruction
one thing that movies and TV tend to get
wrong about destructive AI is that it
always seems to take the form of a
humanoid robot in reality a super AI
would have no need for a single human
shaped enclosure a sentient software
based AI could travel instantly between
electronic devices and inhabit many of
them at once
making it impossible to get rid of a
single evil robot makes for good TV but
in the real world we'd probably be dead
before we even realized the mistake we
had made of course this may not come to
pass humans have a way of surviving our
most destructive inventions at least so
far and even using that same technology
to improve our lives the same could be
true of artificial intelligence if we
could develop an AGI and train it to
experience human emotions such as
empathy we could potentially create the
most powerful force for good in the
history of mankind a benevolent AI whose
only task is to improve the lives of
humans and work towards a greater good
could make for a future free of disease
hunger and suffering this AI wouldn't
even have to be fully sentient if it was
intelligent enough to be turned loose on
difficult problems but lacked any kind
of motive or self-awareness as long as
we were careful with instructions we
could have an incredibly useful
software-based assistant that could be
put to work over a very wide range of
applications we could even integrate
with this AI in the future by augmenting
our brains to run the software kind of
like a super advanced personal assistant
in your head able to fetch answers teach
you new things and help you make
important decisions no one's really sure
what will happen when we finally reach
the singularity but whatever happens it
will change the course of history
forever the future of humanity is one of
our favourite topics here at second
thought so we were more than happy to
partner with cheddar on this episode
cheddar recently launched their own
YouTube channel and are making videos
that cover business technology media and
news but without the boring parts I just
watched their episode about avoiding a
robot uprising and I highly recommend
you check it out too and if you liked it
consider subscribing to their channel
which has tons of other fun and
informational content and watch more of
their videos